I mean I I mean that I think that's one
of the reasons I've always loved you and
everything you do is like there's a
level of authenticity um and it's like
like earlier we were talking about style
and stuff and I'm like I love your style
because it's it's just you're
effortlessly doing it whatever you like
you know or unless there's a lot of
effort I don't know I mean it took a
while to stay in there and be like I
don't know if this is okay but try to
wear that black coat cuz I know you like
black
stuff I love that I wish I could be as
Brave as you I think I did think that's
the reddest lipstick I've ever seen in
my life but it's kind of a nice
Christmas color too wait what do you
mean Brave I think it's just Brave to
put this
on to be like uh like cuz I remember
when I was in junior high school my
friend Matt Shin he was like he was a
neat guy and his brother played in a
band and I don't want to say the band
was bad but the band was probably had a
unique sound okay okay so and their name
was like uh uh you know like um
shuttering like it was something crazy
you know like desperate victim or
something you know like
definitely like the the name of the B
was one guy was playing the drums but he
was he was just [__] shaking with
anger so much and he had the sticks in
his hand and he was just keeping some
type of a vague wooden a metal falsetto
and it was just that's who they were you
know but so I would go sometimes and try
to be like and I would listen to like
Blind Melon and like [__] blind melon
is like the one
the I can say is that my life but they
somehow rolled I guess they weren't goth
but they were kind of hippie I don't
know if we had goth maybe we had one
dude oh yeah goth was different sorry
these were just kind of like like the
opposite yeah these were just kind of
like like violent hippies okay all right
so that's kind of the group I was in for
a little while was this violent hippie
group and then um but yeah the goth kids
would wear like those shoes that were
like and
then but they had to wait till everybody
left to walk back because it was like
such a uncomfortable walk sometimes she
like why are those goth kids still
hanging out by the tree over there like
they're always in the trees it's weird
there's even a website I think it was
called Goths in trees and for some
there's like a fascination with like
goth people that are like in trees I
didn't I've never felt the feeling
calling but I don't know there's a lot
of them that's cool it's a thing so go
on there it is Goss and trees right
there let's look at a few of them they
all hang out that guy not that go yeah
that guy definitely oh that guy is goth
dude yeah they all hang out in trees I
don't understand oh there is something
very Edgar Alan Poe about
it you know CU they're because of a
raven I think so now this lady seems
like it's a thing I have never done it
let's see more this is fascinating wow
now that guy is goth yeah look they're
inside trees it's
weird I wonder if there's something
about it that feels good to
them to our
species yeah I could see it now this is
really interesting she brought props oh
yes she's a Sith uhhuh or Scythe or is
it Scythe she's a scythe oh wow yeah
these are gos on on uh in trees it a
tree house or yeah it looks like a tree
house or zipline gosip on zipline would
be good
too but I love this this is really
fascinating um I used to love when there
was some dope Tumbl Pages out there that
was fun wasn't it yeah but wait you were
going to get to that the point where so
you had the friends that were in the
band and yeah but yeah and I thought I
was goth but I wasn't I guess yeah we
would just like listen to like skinny
puppy or different bands like you know
uh epilepsy lizard or some kind of [__]
like that and then um yeah that was it
that was about his guy
as kind of as goth as I get but I was
always marveled at the people that could
go full Darkwing Duck you know like
people like that Darkwing Duck yeah I
think the people that like could be like
whoa like this person like how did they
get to school they flew here themselves
like that type of I think there was
something like interesting about it yeah
yeah and there was always like there's
such an Allure I think about that sort
of woman or I would probably say woman
more because I think it's like
a there's something interesting
about a goth person what is it what is
it about goth people why is it like a
like the loose screws probably or what
is it like why do they what is like the
the the calling towards like is there
like a code of conduct or something I
mean there's got to be um some childhood
stuff right I mean I know for me I I
like I said I never felt a sense of
belonging even within my own family unit
um
so I remember discovering music and then
not necessarily seeing myself but um
like there was a reflection of emotions
happening like when I I like I Love The
Cure and Susan the banshe she the p and
I think like Lally and just like this um
the soul to it you know I feel like a
lot of people are sensitive in that
sense but and then they just like take
it to the you know to the outward
expression of that but
I don't know I I just I just like it you
know always maybe that's it maybe like a
way to be seen too because I guess it
was an outlier like I grew up in a small
town so but but it's kind of not cuz
like right cuz you have your own group
then like is that what you mean well I
mean I don't know I I'm not judging I'm
just looking at it I'm like it's just
it's funny like even this morning when I
was getting ready I was like you know I
feel like I tend to dress very I cover
all the time like I don't I very rarely
show my tattoos at all I was like you
know I'm going to change it up I'm going
to go see Theo today and I'll just wear
short sleeved you know but I feel like I
would always get tattooed for myself
like I just like to look at images or I
like what it looks like with the
appearance of it um I in the middle of
nowhere in Indiana like I dress like
this every day like and it's like but
it's not for anybody else other than why
are you laughing I can just see how many
men got have like pulled up back at home
like honey I seen a damn apparition down
now that damnest neighborhood's going to
[__]
so really I think there's something
interesting about or no there's some
look I think a lot of men I remember in
our town a lot of men would go and cry
over by the wind Dixie in their truck I
remember why I don't know why but we
would go ride our bike over there
sometimes it was like a sad place like I
think men would just go sit over there
and be sad sometimes but I remember
seeing that but um yeah I think there
was something very Allure ing about a
goth woman to me it seemed like a siren
you know like in that book yeah for
Odysseus you know what I'm talking about
yeah yeah it seemed that's what it
seemed like there was like something
like what's going on yeah this is
different it's different you know I
think it's well it's Brave to be
different I think so that may be like
yeah was an element of like this feels
Brave to me like I'm just interested how
somebody kind of leans into that or how
they you
know not that they're joining a group
but it's like what how does that kind
of yeah why does why does one goth you
know yeah I I mean I don't know I just
like what I like I think and I
just do more of that or do a lot of that
I guess yeah yeah it's interesting I've
never gotten you know I think there's
maybe I might have dated a goth woman at
some point I don't remember but I
probably I think I could have I think I
did did she didn't write you a poem huh
I'm sure she did I'm sure we do we get
uh we do a lot of family portraits
together and I like I love our little
family because we just we look like a
little family you know like my
son
he is not scared about like what I think
not scared but like spooky to him is fun
because it's what he's around you know
what I mean so his normal is a lot
different than like normal kids and we
get a lot of criticism about that too cu
um you know he cuz he wears black or
he'll like I'm like that's what he likes
like at this point he sees his dad or
his mom you know it's like it's it's
normal to him so so we did like a photo
shoot for this uh it was actually for
like a an interview like for a magazine
thing and they wanted to shoot us in
front of our house and so I was like oh
let's there's like this little Fountain
and I had like my little like Tim Burton
like parasol thing and um and people
just hated it I think they just hated
sing like it bothers them that we we
don't look normal I don't understand
it's really weird you should get your
son a vulture or something for Christmas
you're
like I bet anyway sorry sorry sorry for
making so many jokes about love your
aesthetic and stuff but it's cool I
never some are very accurate though well
I wish I gotten to talk to more people
that light are goth people I think I
think I don't ever do I don't know if I
don't go to enough goth places I think
I've always kind of had affinity for
goth women maybe I think oh my brother
likes goth women too I think or he likes
Creative Ladies kind of like artsy yeah
and yeah I think where I was growing up
being artsy was weird you know I think
it was like people thought you was gay
or something you know or you was damn
gay or whatever if you you know did like
I remember if you got good grades you
know people thought you were homosexual
you know really oh yeah dude and so it
was like yeah so I think being brave
enough probably where and when I was
little to have uh somebody
be like unique yeah like you seem uh
like you are I think it that would have
been so maybe that's why I think it's
really fascinating I may I think it's
maybe the trauma like that's like like
because I think about why does it why do
I think cigarettes are sexy right like
because there's this like sense of
like you don't care that you're damaging
yourself and there's like a not a danger
to it but just like it's
self-destructive a little bit and I
think with maybe it's
just
like there I don't know like some some
of my favorite bands and the music I
listen to It's like there's some stuff
that I'm like oh they're they're good
but you could tell they just like they
don't have any trauma like so it's like
I just don't listen to happy I don't
like Happ I don't I'm not attracted to
it you know what I mean yeah um so yeah
maybe that's what it's what it takes I
know I've had had trauma I mean I've
seen some crazy things do a lot of
people mistake you and Dave Navaro ever
or not no but you know what I do hate is
like um because I really want to have
bangs and every time I've ever cut bangs
people call say that I look like share
and I don't think I look anything like
Sher I think it's because we have a deep
voice right oh yeah that could be it I
saw Sher at a game she was running
around with a young brother out of out
of out of at the Super Bowl last year
yeah yeah she's dating like a
17-year-old I think 18 sorry yeah but um
yeah um yeah but I don't look like Dave
Navaro take that back sorry you don't
look anything like David I was just
trying to think if like somebody were
like really ridiculous that they would
run up and say
that